إنها علامة فظيعة
في عام 2020 ، مات أكثر من 93000 شخص
من جرعات زائدة من المخدرات ،
ما يقرب من 30 زيادة
مسجلة أعلى رقم سجله مركز السيطرة على الأمراض على الإطلاق في فترة 12 شهرًا.
وراء
معظم الوفيات الناجمة عن الجرعات الزائدة ويعتقد بعض
الخبراء أنه ليس من قبيل المصادفة
الوصول إلى هذا الرقم القياسي في عام 2020.
نحن نعلم أن الوباء تسبب في الكثير من
التوتر
والحزن والصدمات وهذا ساهم
في اليأس الذي يشعر به الناس
باستخدام الأدوية وفي النهاية تناول جرعة زائدة من
الدكتور جوشوا شارفشتاين
تقول مدرسة جون هوبكنز بلومبيرج للصحة العامة إن
هناك عوامل أخرى تشمل عدم استقرار إمدادات الأدوية
مما يسمح للفنتانيل بالاستمرار في تولي
زمام الأمور في أجزاء مختلفة من البلاد
، كما أن الوباء جعل من الصعب الحصول على
العلاج من
المخدرات والخدمات التي نعرفها أشياء تعمل من
أجل الإدمان والجرعات الزائدة
ونحتاج إلى القيام بالمزيد منها ، نحتاج إلى
الاستثمار في تلك الاستراتيجيات
من أجل رؤية ذلك
يقول الدكتور شارفشتاين إن هناك حاجة أيضًا
إلى التركيز على الأقليات
التي تتأثر بشكل غير متناسب بكل من
covid19
والجرعات الزائدة من المخدرات تتعرض المجتمعات الملونة
بشدة لأكبر
ارتفاع في عدد الوفيات الناجمة عن الجرعات
الزائدة وأعتقد
أن هذا مرتبط بالوباء ولكن د.
يقول شارفشتاين إنه مع التعافي من الوباء ،
هناك أمل في دقيقة الصحة أنا ماندي
جيثر